at nestle we have introduced a creating
shareholder value report where we have
quite a big balance sheet of the most
different aspects this has to do with
shasta with ecological sustainability
how many water we have saved how many
less energy we are needing but you also
have for example in our case nutrition
aspects how many products have been
reformulated in order to have less fatty
acids or how many have less sugar we
have saved about 250,000 tons of sugar
which we have taken out of our product
we have taken out more than 5,000 tons
of salt in our products and we report
this to our shareholders the exactly the
same way as we are reporting the
financial results so I think this is one
way in order to be sure that we also
monitor what we are promising and that
this is not just the words and our
shareholder can see that now the good
thing is that in many of those things
both the societal interests and the
shell the inter skills hand-to-hand if
we able for example like we did in our
water business to make our plastic
bottles light and we are using today a
third of the plastic that will be using
some years ago for a bottle or when we
are recycling these bottles into for
example pensions and and and other
product well it is good for society but
it was also good for us because we were
able to bring our costs down they said
we have been able to save 1.5 billion of
the swiss francs last year in different
efficiency program that we had so this
is a way how we can combine the interest
of society and the interests of our
shoulder that's what we call internally
creating shared value
yeah I think there are tools two aspects
to this first of all they are quite a
big group of shareholders who demand
from us independently of the yearly
report they demand from us what we are
doing in the area of creating shared
value special reports additional reports
and they will tell us that only if we
embrace this Prada stakeholder concept
would they continue to be our
shareholders we have also seen that we
are more attractive for the long term
value shareholders then perhaps for very
short term shareholders who have more
interest to see fluctuations in our
share price that's not the type of
shareholders that we want we want to
really to be attractive and to be the
best performing long-term value
shareholders that's what our target is